the accountant stars Ben Affleck JK
Simmons Anna Kendrick and Jon Bernthal
the Punisher himself and all of his epic
glory and is directed by Gavin O'Connor
and it's the story of a young boy who's
very socially introverted who deals with
autism while also being able to do
things like puzzles upside down an
extreme math far beyond his years
this boy grows into Ben Affleck who
becomes an accountant for some of the
worst criminal organizations in history
and he just might so have a badass set
of skills
now I loved warrior I thought warrior
was really fantastic so I was looking
forward to the accountant just based on
Gavin O'Connor's involvement the trailer
also really sold me now here's what I
really like about this movie quite a bit
what really surprised me about the
accountant based on the trailer is that
this movie takes its time to tell its
story very slowly now I'm not saying
it's slow paced I'm just saying it took
a surprising amount of effort and care
to flesh out its characters and not just
Ben Affleck but Anna Kendrick's
character who comes in as an associate
who first notices a flaw with this one
company's numbers and that's how she
meets Ben Affleck because he gets called
in to do the books for this company JK
Simmons as an officer close to retiring
who's working with another girl to
figure out who this guy is and where
he's from and he has a very checkered
past
and the past is something that's very
important to this film because we
flashback quite often to see Ben
Affleck's childhood and we learn about
how he was raised we see how his parents
dealt with his autism how he learned to
deal with it and how this molded him
into a person because his dad is like
this hardcore military guy who literally
takes him to fight trainers to teach him
to do all of these really amazing things
just as a boy so when he grows up not
only is he this incredibly smart person
who can function at such a high level
when it comes to things like math he
also can kick an absurd amount of s so
he takes both of these traits and
combines them to be a very sought-after
person see I know Matt Damon and Ben
Affleck are good friends in real life
and I couldn't help but think that this
was sort of like a combination of Good
Will Hunting and Jason Bourne
mathematician extremely smart
badass spy thrown into one it just I
couldn't help but notice the comparison
and it made me smile but as I said this
movie took a surprising amount of time
with its characters to really flesh them
out and to give them a backstory and to
give them a history and that's something
I appreciated because although I love
movies like John wick that are a little
more conventional than the accountant is
I appreciated that this film really took
a lot of time to make us care about
these characters so that when there is
action which by the way is extremely
well filmed and choreographed very
fast-paced and hard-hitting
bare-knuckled when that happens you care
more about the people that are involved
in these sequences because I would
hesitate to call this an action film in
our common definition of it it is most
certainly technically in action film and
you will probably see this blu-ray
listed in the action genre when you go
to buy it at Best Buy or whatever but
it's more of a drama that contains
action sequences that help propel the
story along and help flesh out the
characters more because the action well
fun is never used as just a sequence for
action purposes generally whenever there
is an action scene it has something to
do with the characters it propels the
drama along in some way it gives them
more to talk about and gives us more to
be interested in and I was really
impressed by that this is one of the
better performances I've seen from Ben
Affleck I thought he was very excellent
as this character you really want to
know what's going on behind his eyes he
is very socially introverted he has a
hard time communicating with people but
at the same time you can tell that he
wants to and it's such an interesting
character as you watch him deal with
wanting to snap when things don't go
proper for him in the way that his mind
wants them to go and he tries to deal
with it through strobe lights and heavy
metal music and hurting himself and I
find that really interesting and I got
to say as someone who has worked with
autistic children in the past because
before I did this I worked on school
buses with handicapped kids I was a
supervisor / monitor aide for school
orthopedic routes and I can say the kids
in this film who portray autistic
children did such a fantastic job
because sometimes when I see actors
trying to do that in movies they go way
over the top they go very Hollywood and
it just doesn't work for me because I've
seen it in real life so
often they really got that aspect of
this film right and that's something I
really respect I feel though that I must
warn you that this is a very
unconventional narrative this is a film
that doesn't give you all the answers
there are scenes that you see that are
played out very early particularly a
jail scene with Jeffrey Tambor and Ben
Affleck and you don't find out what that
was until almost the very end of the
movie and there are sequences like that
in this film that require you to think
and they require you to pay a lot more
attention than your average action
thriller would and because this film is
so unconventional and different in its
approach that leads me to one of my
minor flaws this film has a lot of
comedy it has romantic comedy it has
action it has drama it has a story about
parents trying to deal with raising an
autistic child it has a lot of things
going for it and it doesn't always mesh
perfectly the tone is sometimes a little
broken but this is a minor thing because
I appreciated that I was watching a film
that told its story differently that
didn't try to do exactly what every
other film of this kind does there's
also one scene near the end that is the
big exposition dump scene where one
character explains a lot of things that
we need to know because as I said the
film has a lot of Secrets and keeps a
lot of information from us so when we
get to that scene it's nice to know
certain things but it does kind of go on
and on and on like I get it you're
explaining things I probably could have
figured some of these out on my own
there's also an extremely unexpected
scene and that's all I'm going to say
near the end and I was just like I
genuinely that floored me that that
floored me cuz the accountant really
surprised me I think this film will not
be for everyone I think some people may
go to this film and want a little more
action some people may find it a little
too narrative ly weird but I like the
fact that this film respects its
audience and asks you to be attentive
and asks us as audience members to
really watch this film and search for
the answers and I think that's really
cool I'm going to give the accountant
and a -
definitely check this one out it's one
of Ben Affleck's best performances and
Gavin O'Connor has made another really
good movie I feel also I want to let you
guys know that I am running a brand new
sponsorship on my channel for my viewers
with Adam tickets this is a mobile app
in which you can purchase tickets and
even pre-order concessions right from
your phone which is extremely awesome
because who likes lines I mean does
anyone like lines I don't I hate lines
if you go and download the app for Adam
tickets and use my name Chris you'll
receive five dollars off your entire
order for the rest of the year that's
pretty awesome one of the coolest
features is rally my friends where you
can pick a film a day and time and then
send this film to your friends and they
can pull whether or not they want to see
that one or another one that is so
friggin gold like I said check out Adam
tickets the mobile app and use my name
Chris and you can get $5 off your order
for the rest of the year and that is
awesome thank you guys so much for
watching you guys are the best
definitely check out the accountant I'm
curious to know what you think of this
film thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
you